This video is brought to you by Squarespace from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Check out Squarespace through the link in the description below more on them in
a bit.
Okay.
It was a feudal leader who emerged as the leader of the odor clan during the
late 16th century. Once he was in power ODA,
Nobunaga embarks on an ambitious plan. So once again,
unite the entire country under the rule of a strong,
determined and ruthless leader. Him,
this was at a time when such a feat seemed almost impossible to accomplish
Japan's authority had been completely decentralized.
And although the country had an emperor render Shogun, neither one wielded,
any real power. Instead,
it had been disseminated among the dozens of Lords who constantly fought each
other for territory gains the idea that one man would be able to bring them all
under his control through alliances and through force seemed one destined to
fail from the outset.
And yet it happens ODA Nobunaga turns into the defacto leader of Japan by
becoming the most powerful Lord in the country,
but he never got to actually rule it as has of a new central governments because
he fell victim to betrayal. Before this could happen,
the mission then fell upon two of his most trusted allies who took the plan of
ODA Nobunaga to completion and together,
they became known as the three great unifies of Japan.
Uh.
In order to get a better sense of ODA Nobunaga's reign and his impact on the
history of Japan.
We should first start with a quick look at the state of the country itself.
During the 16th century, our story takes place during the Shogun era of Japan,
a time period that lasted almost 700 years until the Meiji restoration of
1868. During this age,
the emperor of Japan still existed and was theoretically the head of state,
but he had no real power. It was more of a ceremonial title.
The defective leader of Japan was a military dictator called a Shogun.
He exerted his power over all of the provinces of the country by points in
governor's called Shu to handle the day-to-day operations over centuries.
This position evolved and was eventually replaced by dime yo a much more
powerful feudal Lord who had actual authority and ownership over his lands while
still retaining certain obligations and responsibilities towards his Shogun to
make matters even more chaotic ODA Nobunaga lived during the Singani periods.
Also known as the age of warring States,
one of the most violent and most unstable periods in Japanese history.
At the outset of this period,
the Shogun had lost most of the authority that he used to have over his dying
years. This triggered a civil war or the Onin war in 1467,
which plunged Japan into a 150 year long power struggle between the country's
most dominant dinos. While this resulted in a loss of battles,
conspiracies and civil Wars, no single dime,
yo proved himself strong enough to permanently defeat his enemies and rule over
a United Japan. Once more, nobody that is until ODA.
I don't have an AGA was born on June the 23rd, 1534,
somewhere in the Ord province. Most likely the city of [inaudible].
He was the oldest son of [inaudible] and his wife daughter goes in,
although Nobel Hedy also had an older legitimate son named Odin Nobel hero.
Nobody. He was the leader of the ODA clan.
And just to clarify Japanese names to start with the family name first,
which in this case is odor speaking of names when he was a child Nobunaga was
actually called kapashi naming conventions of feudal.
Japan are quite complex for the upper classes and as they changed their names,
at least once during their lifetimes and even up to four or five times,
boys started out with a yo-yo meaning youth name,
which later changed to the Amena or true name when they were teenagers as part
of their passing into manhood. Then there was also the hereditary title,
the clan name and to the pseudonym,
but let's keep it simple and stick with ODA Nobunaga.
Since that is the name that most people are familiar with during his time,
Japan was theoretically ruled by the Ashikaga Shogun AIDS.
Although this was just nominally,
even though the Ashikaga had been in power since the mid 14th century,
they never really owns that much personal territory.
This is not ideal when you want to operate a military dictatorship.
So the Ashikaga will always rely on the loyalty of that dinos over the
235 years that this Shogun stayed in power.
The influence and authority of the Damian Lords kept increasing creating a
situation where some clans easily equal the Shogun eight in power,
even though technically they were still subservience.
Obviously it was only a matter of time until somebody came along with ambitions
of conquest to put the strength of the shogunate to the test.
The main reason why it took so long for a dime year to challenge the Shogun was
because they were always busy fighting among themselves during Naheed days.
Rain, the ODA clan was mainly preoccupied with neighboring cyto and
[inaudible] was weaker than his opponents,
mainly due to internal strife inside his own clan and was defeated by each one
in battle because of this,
he decided to make peace with the scientific clan and did leader cyto docent by
marrying Nobunaga to docents daughter and a He-Man better known as the lady.
Now, this all is known about her and the ultimate fate is on certain,
but we do know that she and that were Naga were never close because lady knew
could not give them any children. After he became diamond.
Nobunaga lavished much more attention on one of his concubines named Kitsilano
who gave him his first son, ODA Novo, Tada.
We're getting.
A bit ahead of ourselves at the moment. No day was still head of the odor clan,
but he died suddenly in 1550, one aged, only 40 or 41 years old.
There was already some internal fighting going on,
but his death created a succession crisis. Nobo hero is Nova Mohita.
His eldest son wanted to succeed him as head of the clan,
but because he was a legitimate, it's not many supported his claim.
And he immediately suffered a defeat against the Imigawa clan,
which caused everyone to lose whatever confidence they had in him to begin with.
It would have made the most sense for Nobunaga to follow his father's footsteps,
but he also lost the support of many of Nobel heaters,
retainers being spoiled and done disciplines. According to legend,
he behaved very poorly at his father's funeral.
And this lack of respect made many former vassals of Noah.
HIDA prefer that his younger son odor Nova Yuki would succeed him as head of the
clan.
Linda was Nobel Hedy's brother odor Novo Tomo who made it play for himself as
the new clan leader in the outside world.
The ODA clans newest Dalai cyto dos and was facing a threat of his own.
When his son's cyto.
You should ask Sue staged a coup assassinated his own du brothers and waged war
against his father for leadership of the Sci-Tech clan. Lastly,
let's not forget that the odor clan was still at war with the Imigawa clan led
by Emma Galois Yoshimoto. As you can see,
the warring States period of Japan certainly lived up to its name.
It was full of treachery violence and one battle after another,
in a constant struggle for power and somehow ODA Nobunaga was the one who
managed to reach the top.
It's hard to say exactly what were his keys to success because he was never
portrayed as some kind of military genius. And in his youth,
at least he was shown to be some undisciplined brat who didn't even want to
assume leadership of the ODA clan, less alone,
set himself on a path to conquer all of Japan as positive the legends
surrounding Nobunaga it, it says this an episode,
which had a profound effect on him occurred when his former tutor a samurai
named Hirata and Massey HIDA committed seppuku out of shame of how his pupil act
is.
This was supposedly what prompted Nobunaga to straighten up and take his role
seriously, but it is likely only a story.
There is a death of contemporary sources on ODA Nobunaga and those that
exist have been greatly exaggerated,
making it hard to get a sense of the real man behind the legends.
Perhaps the best description we have comes courtesy of Portuguese missionary,
Louis FRA,
who became a close friends with the Lord and even stayed at his residence for a
while. Decades often Nobunaga became dime yoke.
He described Nobunaga as a tall man,
thin scantily bidded with a very clear voice,
much given to the practice of arms Hottie funds of the exercise of justice and
of mercy. Prouds. I love her on, uh,
to the uttermost very secretive and what he determines extremely shrewd in the
stratagems of war little, if at all,
subject to the reproof and council of his subordinates feared and revered by all
to an extreme degree does not drink wine.
He is a severe master treats all the Kings and princes of Japan with scorn and
speaks to them over his shoulder as though to inferiors and is completely obeyed
by all as that absolute Lord. Now,
just before we get into the rest of today's video,
I do want to take a quick moment to tell you about today's sponsor Squarespace.
Now, a couple of simple things,
maybe you've got an idea for a website or a business that you want to start or
something in your mind. You're thinking maybe I should try that. Well, too.
The only way to find out whether that's a good idea is to get it out there to
the world.
And this can be daunting because it's scary to go and pursue new things,
but not knowing how to set up a website is not excuse.
There are no excuses available with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to.
We want to sell something online. Yes. Set up a store with Squarespace.
You want to start a podcast? Absolutely. You can do that too.
It all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template that you can customize to
your heart's content.
Or you can start from scratch or you can move over easily from an existing
domain, making everything super easy to manage. Don't start from scratch though.
Just use a template, no excuses.
And once you've gone through the super easy customization process,
there's no updates.
There's no patches there's make tack the S to deal with and Squarespace.
They also handle all of that website stuff. Podcasts. Yes. Mailing lists. Sure.
Social media integration, absolutely. And a whole lot more.
Also there's 24 seven customer support in case you get stuck,
but you probably won't have distress based.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
save 10% off your first purchase of a website or a domain
Naga to fulfill his ambitions.
He had to assume uncontested control of the ODA clan,
which meant dealing with his younger brother and his uncle.
First up was his uncle ODA Novo Tomo who had taken control of Kiyosaki castle in
1553 and had the support of the Sheba plan of Matsu province.
Despite this Nobunaga had no real difficulty in this basil. And in 1555,
he captured his uncle who was forced to commit suicide.
Nobunaga's then relocated to Nagoya castle making Kiyosumi his new base of
operations.
ODA noble Yorkie proved more difficult to submit because he had more retainers
on his side who still viewed him as the best candidate to take over the clan.
The two sides met in battle in 1556 on the, in a plane,
despite being heavily outnumbered.
Another Naga was victorious and afterwards even forgave his brothers and his
retainers, mostly due to the pleading of his mother, Dota goes in even.
So nobody Yorkie did not stop plotting against his brother and intended to rise
up against him once more when he was not expecting it. However,
his retainers proved to be a bit more honorable than he gave them credit for
after being defeated, they swore their loyalty is a NABA.
Naga runs intended to keep this oath. Nova Yorkie informed them of his plans.
And one of them named Shibata cat Sui tolls Nobunaga of his brother's treachery.
This time, the leader of the ODA clan could no longer forgive his brother.
So he had to know where Yorkie assassinated at kiosk to console in 1557.
By this point, Noah Naga was pretty firmly in control of his own clan.
So it was time to expand his attention to his neighbors, his ally,
and father-in-law cyto dos and died at the battle of nag or a river in
1556. I just treacherous on Yosha.
Tatsu became the new leader of the clan besides wanting to avenge dos and Noah
Naga.
Also might've had a rightful claim to his lands is the old man allegedly named
his son-in-law was his main beneficiary and his will.
And the new Lord of the Mino province.
Nobunaga tried to defeat Yasha Tatsu in battle several times,
but the lots have proved to be a wealthy folk.
Although successful in combat the leader of the [inaudible] clan was taken down
by an unexpected foe, an illness that killed him in 1561,
just age 35. He was succeeded by his son, cytotoxic chokey,
who was young and experienced and completely unprepared for the new role that
was forced upon him. He managed to hold his own for a few years,
but the cyto grant soon became irrelevant in the power struggle going on in the
country. Finally,
Nobunaga defeated him conclusively at the siege of inner Bayamo castle in
1567 and the Sci-Tech clan disappeared for him.
Nope.
Still had one more enemy to deal with Imigawa Yoshimoto and he was the most
powerful of all. Also aided by the matzoh direct clown of Macau province,
which was a long-standing enemy of the odor in 1560 Yoshimoto assembles,
a long army of 25,000 mens, a March on the Capitol of Kyoto,
the seat of power of the Shogun AIDS,
his exact intentions have never been made clear and have only been speculated by
later historians.
Some believe he only wants it an official sanction from the shoguns legitimize,
his actions against Theo to clan while others thought he or she Moto might've
intended to bring down the Shogun at itself on the way that he entered a watery
province,
which belonged to the ODA clan and began plundering and capturing castles.
Following the siege of marinade,
the Matsudaira clan managed to seize the strongest of Nobunaga's fortresses in
the region. Obviously the odor clan had to respond,
but nobody knowing his forces were only a small fraction of Yashi motos.
He may have had around 5,000 men at his disposal,
but some still have to be left behind to defends the other properties in a
warrior.
I had an attack would have been suicide and does advise is warmed up to fall,
back to Keo SU Casa Lynn's prepare for a siege Nobanaga however,
it felt that such a move would only delay that downfall and that their only
chance was a strong and unexpected counter attack,
which happens at the battle of Oka Hosanna in June,
1560 Yoshimoto in his army set up camp at the foot of Mount Hazara.
On the day of the attack, as men were busy,
celebrating their victories with cheers and Sockeye. Well,
the [inaudible] was allegedly entertaining himself by inspecting the heads of
his enemies,
which he had collected during this time Nobunaga runs around 2000 of his men
managed to sneak their way into the nearby Nakashima fortress undetected.
Allegedly the older leader went to great lengths to make his enemies thing that
he was someplace else.
Even if it means giving up a significant part of his already small army,
he sent hundreds of soldiers to lay siege on the roomy castle while others were
stationed.
There were a temple with lots of flags and banners to exaggerate the numbers in
case an enemy scalps spotted them. Undoubtedly,
it was also assisted by a large storm, which hit the camp that day,
making it much harder for Yoshimoto his men to spot their enemy when the
downpour ended Nobunaga and his men challenged into the unsuspecting camp and
attacked this caused immediate Mehan and confusion and allegedly Yoshimoto
himself was so taken aback that he initially believed drunken brawl had erupted
between his men. By the time he realized what was happening,
it was too late to organize any sort of defense.
The soldiers of the Imigawa clan were fleeing for their lives in every direction
while Yoshimoto himself was attacked and killed by two of Nobunaga samurai.
And that Tori cuts Tata and Maury or HSA katsu, ODA Nobunaga returns,
triumphant Tokyo suit castle with his vanquished foes had proudly on display.
This was a major shift in the balance of power. Prior to this battle,
there was a real chance that our worry province would fall completely in the
hands of the amygdala clan. While the ODA clan might have disappeared forever.
Now, ODA Nobunaga was one of the most powerful,
most respected and most feared warlords in the country.
And he samurai in his mind,
a diamond has pledged their allegiance to Nobunaga including his former enemies
Matsudaira clan.
They were led by matzoh Diara Mata Jasu to become one of Nobunaga's strongest
allies later on,
he would change his name to talk with Galileo Sue and who would play just as
important to roll in Japan's unification this Oh, to Nova Naga,
but that's a story for another day.
Yeah.
1868 Golden opportunity presented itself to Nobunaga during the previous years,
while the ODA Demio was busy, fighting his enemies,
the show guns had their own problems and conspiracies to deal with when this
whole thing started, the Shogun of Japan was Ashikaga Yasha, Terri 13,
the Shogun of the Ashikaga dynasty. However, in 1565,
he was slaying in basil by a group of dinos.
He wanted to install his cousin as Chicago,
Yara Shahidi as the new Shogun who would basically serve as that puppet like we
previously mentioned. But at this point in the show,
grenades was a mere shell of what it used to be.
And the Shogun himself was only as powerful as the dime.
You're willing to go to war for him.
Not everyone was cool with Yasha HIDA as the new Shogun.
And among those people was Yoshiaki the younger brother of the 13th Shogun who
was betrayed and kills. He wants it, his revenge,
and also wants to take back the show grenades,
but then he needed the support of a strong and respected Diageo.
And there was no better candidates than odor Nova Naga.
The leader of the ODA clan was perfectly happy to assist Yoshiaki with this task
because after all the new Shogun would be his puppets and Nova Naga would be the
true leader of the country. In 1568,
they marched on Kyoto with their main obstacle,
being the rock of clan of army province,
neither rock Akron or any of the other clans, however,
proved able to stop Noah Naga.
And by the end of the war Ashikaga Yoshiaki was the new Shogun. However,
this Alliance only lasted for a few years.
Yoshiaki soon grew to resent his position and his dependency on Nobanaga ruins
began plotting against him.
He found plenty of co-conspirators as there was certainly no absence of
[inaudible] begrudge the ever-increasing power of the ODA clan.
There's never led anywhere. However,
because when Nobunaga had had enough of Yoshiaki Jackie's intrigue see easily
deposed him in 1573, thus putting an ends to not only as rain,
but to the entire Chicago Shogun eight. Mm.
During the years of Yankees rain.
The Shogun was the least of Nobunaga's worries.
Virtually every clan leader who was outside his sphere of loyalty and influence
began seeing the odor clan as a powerful enemy and unsurprisingly,
many of them wanted to put a stop to Nobunaga's rise.
It would take far too long to talk about each one here as there were dozens of
clans, both big and small, which opposed the odor leader.
So we'll focus only on the major events.
And we'll start with the battle of Antigua. In 1570,
the fight was the high points of the conflict,
but we know a Naga and the asset Cora clan of each of them province.
One of his strongest foes earlier that same year,
nobody Naga had invited each sin and captured one of the asset Cora castles.
He had declared advantage,
but received words that nearby our side clown had betrayed him.
That's when now coming from behind to trap him, no, a Naga had no choice,
but to retreat,
to Kyoto it previously allied himself to the OSI plan through marriage.
But their relationship with Assa Gara went back decades.
So perhaps it was a bit foolish of NABA Naga to expect them to choose him over
their much older allies, either way in July 15, 17, he launched a new attack.
Cause this time on the OSI stronghold of Adani castle,
he met his enemies in battle and a golfer and scored a significant win.
But the castle remained in the hands of the aside while this was an important
victory that turns the tide in the favor of Nova nugget.
It was by no means the end of his war with the OSI and as Cora clans,
it wasn't until 1573,
the Nobunaga led successful seizures on that consoles forcing his enemy plan
leaders to commit suicide.
The greatest fear of the odor clan during this time was Takita Shingon leader of
the Takita clan of CAI province and Lord of the famous group of skilled military
commanders dubbed the 24 generals.
One of these men of samurai named Yama Nova Tomo showed his value by
taking one of Nobunaga's strongholds era, more, a castle without shedding,
a drop of blood. Instead he convinced the lady of the castle.
No inaug arms lady [inaudible] to betray her Lord surrender to the castle and
accepts Nova tomorrow's hand in marriage.
Often this events and other Naga had no choice, but to engage Takita in war,
the two sides fought in early 1573 at the battle of [inaudible] and
surprise, surprise Takita one indecisive fashion for a while,
it looked like taquito Shingon would be the one to finally put an end to
Nobunaga's ambitions. And we would probably be doing a video about him today.
If fortune did not smile upon ODA Nobunaga once more after his victory,
it's nicotine Hora Takita press. The attack is invaded.
One of Nobunaga's provinces there,
he set up camp and then he died of an unknown illness afterwards,
tacky to his Casio, or he became leader of the clan,
but he was nowhere near as skilled or experienced as his father.
That's only turned firmly and no one August favor following his decisive victory
at the battle of Nagesh Chino in 1575.
And he wiped out the Takita clan completely at the 1582 battle of 10
MACUSA Cruzan where cat, Sierra and committed suicide. Besides the other clans,
ODA Naga also count a powerful enemy in the form of Buddhism warrior,
amongst belonging to a sect called shin Buddhism to be exact ever since he took
power. Nobunaga full to movement called echo EQI,
which consisted of Buddhist commoners, who opposed the rule of dinos.
He burned down their temples and executed that priests,
but they remained a thorn in his side until his death.
[Inaudible].
Almost constant threats of Nobunaga's authority.
He was the defacto leader of Japan for over a decade.
Although we should make it clear that he never actually succeeded in unifying
the entire country under his rule.
He was on his way to accomplishing this goal where it not for the treachery.
He suffered at the hands of one of his samurai called [inaudible].
The reason behind the Kiki's betrayal is uncertain.
Although common theories claim that it happens because of MITSA HiTA his
personal animosity towards his dime you,
or because he wanted to restore the emperor to power.
One popular story involves one of Nobunaga's enemies.
The Tano had a HARO liter of hatano clan of tambour province after Mitzi,
who defeated him in battle. The samurai brought a Tano before his Lord,
after having promised in protection in exchange for his surrender.
Nobunaga however, how Caetano executed anyway, blaming a catchy fullness,
betrayal, platanos, retainers, kidnapped,
and murdered his mother as punishment while we don't know whether this is true
on us,
it fits with Nobunaga's reputation of being ruthless towards his enemies and
indifferent to the problems of his own men.
And it certainly gave Mitsui day a good reason to turn on his master.
It was June, 1582. Nobanaga had just wiped out the Takita clan.
One of his most dangerous adversaries.
He was feeling confident and he was feeling safe.
Most of his army accompanied Docker [inaudible] in another region while ODA
Nobunaga traveled to Kyoto with only a small retinue of servants and court
officials, hearing of this, it catching it's heat, a sore, his opportunity.
He assembled an army of 13,000 men and marched on Kyoto.
They arrived on June the 21st and surrounded the Honnoji temple.
When Onaga was located. He only had a few dozen guards with him.
So there was really no chance of victory,
nor was there any way to stall while waiting for reinforcements.
As the temple arounds him burned to the ground ODA Nobunaga retreated into the
inner sanctum and committed SuperCrew as did his eldest son Novo Tada later that
same day, his death was a shock to the nation.
I catchy going to enjoy the fruits of his betrayal for a whole 13 days before
Nobunaga's other retainers, 40 minute battle and took their revenge for this.
He became known as the 13 day Shogun and the unification of Japan was
handled by two other men who built upon the violent bloody and ruthless
groundwork set out by ODA Nova Naga. So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting. If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe. Please do check it off. Fantastic sponsor as well.
Squarespace. There's a link to that.
Hello. Thank you for watching.